I couldn't receive that do you think I
could I could have received do you think
I could in the office with the red lace
glasses on them troubled glasses on
[Music]
yeah
[Laughter]
man
as you can see we did it we actually did
it we're gonna stop actually talking
about it now because we've finally done
it yeah but let us let us Embrace this
moment are you gonna hear about a lot
today yeah and then yeah go forward yeah
going forward it's over it's over we
need that one million Chase because
we're here now yeah we're not uh we're
not asking for anything anymore yeah you
guys can do what you want yeah you man
can do what you want apart from
unsubscribed facts but yeah one million
YouTube subscribers guys it happened
let's give ourselves a round of applause
[Applause]
um so like to give a little bit of uh
contest actually what we'll do is we'll
do our uh cheeky shot first let's let's
um let the chest get warm and then we'll
get emotional and then I'm probably
gonna do like two or three this episode
and because I'm super happy okay right
guys thank you very very much cheers to
you all
um you guys are the best Cheers bro
cheers and uh yeah man cheers let's do
this Bottoms Up and all that
foreign
I wonder why the phrase is called
Bottoms Up because the bottom of the
thing goes up
so literally the most obvious phrase
anyone has ever met I'm sorry bro yeah
that seconded me that was an L for you
it was let's move on one million right
makes perfect sense
I just say stuff but I love your
innocence I'm not even gonna lie to you
I love your innocence yeah someone's
gotta be right I'm gonna run back a
second right now yeah yeah because I
don't like space them out that much I'd
rather just get the juicy going now yeah
and then like let it like right away
yeah let it ride the way throughout
otherwise because when we used to do it
back in the day
we used to do these like crazy and then
my throat would hurt I started getting
hot you didn't ever know yeah I started
getting hot and dizzy and all this kind
of stuff and by the end of the thing I
was absolutely wasted yeah
um so it's good to just do two or three
in the in the beginning and then just
let it ride out well done G thank you
safe safe safe cheers
if you're new here
I just did is what is commonly known in
the cult baby Community as a tequila sip
sip yes sir we haven't spoke about it in
a very long time yes sir
um
shot pineapple I shot to kill the
tequila followed by a shot of pure
pineapple juice it's the best thing
anyone's ever invented an alcohol game
and um yeah we claim it we do we claim
it there's controversy about who
invented it yeah we claim it and the
fact of the matter is I want to be open
we know we didn't invent it yeah because
it's got introduced to us in the first
place but we claim it yeah man we're
colonizers yeah we just come here and
claim stuff start planting flags and
taking it facts because we can yeah
because we've got a million Subs who's
gonna tell us off we are those guys now
yeah yeah who you're gonna believe Craig
David or Ross fat how many Subs has he
got five probably more but it doesn't
matter
who cares oh 918k is all it says
shut up blood yeah we invented it man no
man I started
what's that I remember that yeah I
remember I remember I remember my first
video
so yeah I'm gonna be like [__] James
today yeah I could tell you I'm on my
Flex where's my sunglasses [__] hang on
what was he saying yeah I remember my
first video
so I'm evil James today okay
because you've got a million Subs I'm
evil James today I'm a flex on all I can
tell G we love to hear it we love to see
you let's go mum Yeah man so guys we did
it we're gasped we hit a million
subscribers on YouTube and for me this
means literally everything I know it
means everything to everyone but um like
to take it all the way back I'm gonna
give props to my boy Lewis again
this dream for me personally literally
started like five years ago six years
ago okay and I've said this on here
before but like as everyone knows if
you've been here for a minute you know
like my like Financial dream obviously
loads of people always want to like
retire their mum or retire their dad or
like buy someone a house like my dream
has always been like I want to buy my
dad an Aston Martin he can afford
whatever flipping car he wants but
that's the car he's never
he loves it and he's never got it and I
don't know why yeah DB9 was his favorite
I don't know if that's still the case
but
he used to love the DB9 it was his
favorite car he never got it and I used
to say to him when I was little I'm
gonna buy that for you I'm gonna buy
that for you and as you know if you've
been here for a while my dad only
respects money yes he doesn't respect
blood money money yeah he does like
blood or loyalty he was just money so
yeah until your money's up shut up yeah
yeah you're in my pocket back pocket at
that yeah sit on you pause
um so anyway I was like I'm gonna buy it
I'm gonna buy I'm gonna buy it so there
was a time where me and my brother had
moved both of us through a breakdown of
simultaneous relationships had moved out
of our respective homes with our
partners back into my mum's and it
happened around about the same time so
all of a sudden we're in our 20s we're
living back up Mom's I'm working at
David Lloyd in Milton Keynes and he was
working for Volkswagen in Milton Keynes
yeah
so because we're broke boys as broke
boys do is we would carpool yeah yeah
yeah yeah so we're carpool and we're
driving and we'll take it in terms as to
who drives and we're driving to Milton
Keynes together from Northampton every
day and we'll just talk and talk and
talk and one thing I love about my
brother is my brother is
um
logical as hell my brother's the most
logical person in the world he doesn't
entertain fantasies and I'm Mr Fantasy
I'm only about the fantasy yeah yeah so
you said bro I'm gonna be so rich and
he's like yeah shut up yeah and then I
used to say we were um in Newport pagnal
um which is a small town outside of
Milton Keynes there is a Aston Martin
dealership okay and it's banging and we
drove past it and I was like bro I can't
wait to buy a dad disaster Martin when
my money's up daddy daddy
and then my brother being my brother
couldn't tolerate it anymore and turned
to me and said
big man no offense like I like this
energy you're giving but where do you
think this money's coming from and I was
like obviously I was working at sale in
sales at the time okay and I was like
obviously bro like I'm gonna
perfect my sales game here at David
Lloyd yeah and I'm gonna move I'm
probably gonna get a sales job in London
selling Tech yeah and my money's gonna
be up yeah and he's like cool best case
scenario how much do you think you're
going to be making and I was like bro
back then like my aspirations I didn't
have I couldn't quantify money like that
yeah and I was like um I don't know like
100k a year and he was like bet good
answer good answer because if you did
get a job in central London doing sales
chances are if you're if you're doing
well you would make 100 Grand a year and
I was like let's go Gucci gang Gucci
gang Gucci yeah and he was like how much
you think an asomime costs yeah I was
like I don't know bro like
200k and he said good answer yeah it
does cost 200k yeah so if you're in Tire
salary before tax is 100k a year on what
planet do you think you're saving 200
Grand to buy someone else a car fam when
I say my head explodes yeah and I was a
competent human being
I was a competent yeah I was a grown-ass
man brought me back down to earth he
drapes me down to earth and I was like
big man this is never gonna happen yeah
like I this actually this thing I've
been talking about since I was five I'm
now 25 and I'm realizing this is never
ever ever gonna happen and I physically
couldn't stand the humiliation yeah and
I like like
this is a dream I've had since I was a
kid yeah you're basically telling me
Santa's not real to my face as a
grown-ass man yeah and I've already
learned that Santa's not real I was
certain this was real and you're telling
me now this is not happening for me
and then he was like this is just life
bro yeah like I'm sorry yeah but you're
not buying anyone anything you're not
buying yourself an Aston Martin you're
not you're sure as [__] nobody yeah and
just come back to reality because it's
boring now it's Wednesday morning we're
driving into Milton Keynes it's cold and
it's boring yeah let's listen to radio
four sharp yeah I just get because this
is a lot yeah this is what we've got
James this is a lot yeah yeah I know you
had dreams yeah this is a lot yeah
and me being me I was like
[__] that yeah like no no no no and I've
always been the kind of person that's
like I'm going to be rich I promise you
that now because I can't not be because
my personality just doesn't reflect it
doesn't reflect like I yeah I don't
reflect broken yeah I don't spend less I
make more fast you know what I mean like
my personality doesn't reflect that kind
of yeah hate to say it can't run So
eventually I don't know how it's gonna
happen but going to make money yeah I
don't know how and I rolled into work
that day
um into David Lloyd into my sales office
I'm a boy who sat opposite me I sat down
ah I sat on a huffed bro
I [__] sat down on halved and he was
like what's up what's up what's going on
um right that's chapter one I'm gonna
take one more shot and then we're gonna
get into steps two okay pause so Aladdin
and Dave Lloyd I've huffed and he's
saying what's wrong
I'm saying what's wrong what's going on
[Music]
so welcome back to chapter two guys
right so to set the scene up just gone
into David Lloyd heartbroken
yeah I've made it into work in my
uniform of all things yeah
um collapse on the chair my heart's
broken my dreams are shattered yeah
Santa's not real and how am I gonna deal
yeah so I sit down Lewis and sat up
opposite means like what's up man and
I'm like bro do you know what's actually
mad and he was like what and I was like
you know how I always bang on about like
and bearing in mind me and Lewis are
equally deluded yes so this ask the
Martin chat he was here for it because
he was chatting Lambos so we was we used
to just ping pong back and forth about
[__] yeah yeah consistent [__]
yeah that was never gonna happen
um
and so I sat down and disheartened my
dreams are crashed and he said bro
what's going on I said bro you know I've
been talking about Aston Martin
and I was like I've just had chat to my
brother and like
it's actually not gonna happen and I
love our little
delusional ping pong and our banter but
like I'm actually deep in it for now
like it's really not gonna happen and I
explained like
what I'd say to my brother my brother
said to me in terms of like bro like
what if we leave here and we get a sick
job doing sales here and we we get a
sick job here and we get promotion there
it's like We're not gonna be making a
million a year yeah like we're we're
really going to be making like 100 Grand
a year and that's banging but that's not
super car chat like and it's really not
and that's the best we're ever gonna get
and it's also going to be a Butters
commute into London yeah every day and
it's also going to be like just
Grim like because it's all it's all well
and good talking about this rich guy
sales chat but let's be real sales is
disgusting and I hate it and we both
hate it and we can talk all this Flex
chat all we want but the reality is is I
hate it I hate it here I hate working
you hate working this is [__] yeah and
all we talk about is getting out of here
but all we talk about is getting out of
here to go to the next office and I hate
it and I can't stand it and I don't want
to do it and bro I was like all of a
sudden all this hype boisterous stupid
chat that we used to dream about that
used to get through the day had all like
plummeted into dust I was like this is
the reality where I'm at bro like this
is [__] and like I'm so heartbroken
I could I could literally cry
um bro it was honestly at that time was
the darkest day of my life and it sounds
stupid for something as Petty as not
buying your dad a Supercar to be the
darkest day of your life but I was
honestly like
I'm so certain I was going to be rich
and now I'm only realizing that it's
impossible for me and 100 grand for a
lot of people is Rich like we did the
the stats that time like what 103 Grand
or whatever it's like top one percent
yeah it's like I can be the top one cent
and I'm still not going to be able to
get Dad that car
um and that's never gonna happen for me
and I was like now I'm just gonna have
to reassess my life goals like what the
[__] am I even doing if I'm not going to
be doing that then why would I even go
to London why would I even do the sales
job I might as well just be a [__] PT
forever I might as well just do
something that's like doable
entertainable like why would I even
bother chasing money if if I can't use
money to get what I want now what's the
point bro the whole thing was the whole
shift was me spiraling down yeah and a
man was like do you know who's got it
good and I was like who's got it good
and he was like bro YouTubers and I was
literally like first of all shut up like
literally shut up I'm pour my heart
you're talking about YouTube bro I'm
giving you everything that's burden to
me yeah and you're saying YouTubers have
it good yeah and [__] is brown bro sky
is blue like why are you chatting
rubbish to me yeah and he was like nah
bro he was like to be fair like I
understand where you're coming from like
I've wanted to be a YouTuber since I was
like nine years old and like I used to
make a YouTube account stream like
Minecraft or stream like this is Lewis
and Lewis okay he was like I used to
make a YouTube account on stream like
not stream but like he would uh back in
the day they would do like Cuts like uh
screen record they would screen
recording voiceover before there was
twitch and streaming and stuff it was
screen recording voice over stuff and
just like
getting like a flipping 25 kill streak
on
called Cod yeah old school card like
World War II card yeah
um and then like he was like I used to
do that and I would do it and like the
videos were actually getting numbers
yeah and he brought up his old YouTube
account and had like 200 views on this
one 300 views in that one and I was like
bro that's actually kind of decent
that's actually 200 people yeah and he
was like yeah and I just quit and I just
never did it and I just never went back
and it's all I've ever wanted to do and
I've been too scared to do it and I was
like oh like that's dark and he was like
bro and I I obsess about YouTube every
day and I see like the lives these
YouTubers live and I watch their Vlogs
and I see them buying apartments in in
L.A and he showed me this one guy and he
was like bro this guy has an apartment
in LA and it was like a vlog tour of his
apartment and like he's like he lives in
London he just bought this like million
pound apartment and he doesn't even live
there and I was like what the [__] and
he was like yeah bro and he's like and
then this is the one that clicked for me
he was like bro it's not even the big
YouTubers that have the money he's like
just an average YouTuber just like not
even it's not the Mr Beast pewdiepies or
anything like it's like just an average
YouTuber is making bags bro like crazy
bags yeah and I was like [__] like what
and then I'm getting hyped again yeah
yeah I'm getting delusional again yeah
and I'm like [__] what do you mean yeah
and he was like bro and then we threw it
yeah yeah and now we're rallied yeah
we're back to town
and he's like bro yeah
yeah and I was like sweat how much yeah
he was like [__] these men are making
10K my 20K 30 40 came off I thought
that's impossible he was like I promise
you're not impossible look at this guy
this guy actually shares his statistics
this guy being Ali abda Ali Abdul her
shout out a million times just at that
time had launched his first ever year in
review video of how much money he made
as a YouTuber and I was like you're
winding me up yeah like and he was like
bro I promise you like he's got the
graph in front of you it literally says
how much he's making every day and I'm
like bro that's impossible
so we're going it going and going and
going and going and I was like oh I love
like and then I was talking about like
oh do you know what my session is like I
would love to be a podcaster like an
obsessive podcast I listened to podcasts
literally eight hours a day it's all I
listen to It's all I care about and I'm
obsessed with it and he was like bro you
could literally put a podcast on YouTube
and you're a YouTuber like you could do
that and I was like oh that's cool
so then
after that conversation I was like I'm
actually going to be a YouTuber now
because I have to buy the Aston Martin
whether for Dad whatever it for me
whether for whatever the [__] I don't
care I have to buy it yeah and I have to
live the dream like Santa is real and I
promise you I'm gonna do it
so from then
we started scheming about how I'm going
to do it and then we're like What do we
like what do we do and the podcasting
thing is like it was like a gap or two
or three steps away from me because I
was like I want to do this podcast thing
but I don't know what to do you don't
have to navigate that yeah I don't I
don't know what you need yeah I don't
know how microphones work yeah I don't
know what XLR cable is I don't know like
anything I don't know how it works I
don't know how they're getting their
voice into a microphone to come on to
like it's not making sense to me so I'm
just going to make videos without a
microphone so what I did was I was like
all right cool so I'm not gonna do a
podcast because I actually don't know
what to do but I'm going to start a
YouTube channel and he was like gang so
I did start a YouTube channel I just
thought I didn't know anything about
making YouTube videos right and I just
made this account started posting videos
about TV and uh film reviews like we do
now thanks I made like five or six
episodes and I was super stoked to buy
it but it was taking ages and I was like
I don't want to just talk about movers
and TV all the time it's boring I like I
love it more than anything but I can't
bothers to just find things to talk
about it's just so jarring I just want
to talk about what I want to talk about
and then we Circle back to the podcast
thing but because I've spent so long on
this channel
I must say so long I meant like a month
but because I've spent so long learning
how to use this and then the comments
will say bro you need a microphone you
sound like [__] so I'm like I'm gonna
have to get a microphone yeah so then I
get a microphone and I learn how to use
that and then like your microphone's not
even turned on like learn how to do your
job yeah so then I learned how to turn
it on and then I learn how to use like
GarageBand that you can
stick this in and it will work on this
and then you learn how to use just like
um
basically everything and then everything
I learned from this channel
meant they're like oh
I actually can start a podcast because
I've learned everything now I've learned
to use a mic I've learned how to use
editing software I know how to use
um everything like I that's what they do
this is what they do and I was like gang
okay cool like I guess we're gonna do it
yeah and then I remember obviously
everyone knows the story I bet you for
Monster muscles podcast you were like no
no no no no then eventually you said yes
so if we skip forward and then we start
the channel and here we are with a
million nearly four years later true
nearly took a minute but yeah we got
here a million subscribers
um and this is all I've ever wanted
because that same day in with Lewis
the same day we were there with Lewis I
remember saying he remember saying I
remember him saying to me a million
subscribers is where it's at because
anyone can call themselves a YouTuber
and you can make money from our 10K 20K
30k 100K 150k 250k 400 500k but the
biggest YouTuber on the planet will
never like turn his nose up for someone
who's got a million subscribers because
it's impossibly hard to do yeah and no
one does it and I think I'd check the
steps yesterday there's like
a stupid like a good few Billion YouTube
accounts makes sense there's a couple
Billion YouTube accounts and 35
000 1 Millions wow
wow Jesus wow yeah so that's like 0.0
Saturn percent of people with YouTube
channels that you have a million subs
and we managed to yeah yeah yeah so um
we're in that category now perspective
yeah and he was like no one can cash it
to you once you get a million once you
get a million
There's No Gray areas you're rich
and you are a YouTuber no one can only
say anything to you so like once you get
to a million that means you've
officially made it yeah and I remember
we've said this a couple times before
when we started this food and I got
together and we set a goals list yeah
and the goals list uh had a million
things on it and I said to him once we
complete this goals list it means we're
on our way once we complete the second
goals list it means we've made it and
the last tick on the second goals list
was a million subscribers on YouTube
yeah um and that was the day that I knew
we would I said to him once we complete
this list we will be rich and we will
have made it yeah I remember I remember
saying it to him because I remember as I
was writing it I was like this is
unachievable
damn this is unachievable but if we ever
do it it means we've made it and we've
done it and we've made we've been made
it
we've been making it bro we've been
making it very very very very very very
um special day today and I'm only deep
in it now that we're talking about it
yeah very very very special day so if
you're still here because I've been
waffling
thank you very very very much because
this is like everything I've ever wanted
in my entire life and to just go full
circle did I stumble into Aston Martin
dealership last week
yeah maybe I did
are they bringing in a brand new db12 in
a couple weeks yeah maybe they are have
I booked myself in for a test drive
possibly
say less is the guy's name Matt from
Aston Martin Newport pagnal yeah yes you
have my personal email address yeah he
does say less
so yes guys we hit a million and we've
made it and as a special celebration
another thing that I've always wanted
was since the day we started this
podcast because this is another
throwback since the day we started this
podcast
who had an eye
only true true true true true like day
one is will know
the day one fans will know fuhad and I
went through drama when we started this
right do you man know how many episodes
never went live because my microphone
wasn't on oh who has microphone wasn't
on yeah we're streaming away I forgot to
flip in press record on the software
forgot about that like I forgot to turn
the camera on yeah the camera turned off
halfway yeah do you mind know how many
times that happened and I had to go home
cry my eyes out when I found out then
drive back to Manchester the next week
when I wasn't due there for three weeks
because we've just been recording like
seven episodes as drive back there the
next week to record again figured I'd
have to book more time off work if we
had like it was so stressful yeah and we
always used to talk bro one day we're
gonna have a studio we're gonna have a
producer we're gonna have an editor we
have to worry about this stuff anymore
because this is [__] jarring yeah
we've lost so many episodes by like [__]
ups yeah and like one thing I'm gonna
say is props to you is this guy's
tolerance for pain is is up because I
would ring in more voice note and
screaming down the phone and I'll say
I'm so sorry because it was up to me it
was up to me and I was so sorry and he
would never not once out of all the
times that happens not once but this guy
turned to me and be like you know what
James [__] off like actually [__] off
like I'm so tired of this like I'm not
taking any more time off work I'm not
doing this I'm not giving up any of my
Sundays I'm not doing this bro not once
did you turn around every single time
his reply would be like
bro you know what it is what it is it's
jarring but it is what it is and I
needed that yeah
so bro thank you for that all good to
you and now we have the producer and we
have the editor and without them without
LS and without it Ram we would never
ever ever ever be where we are today so
we have a special surprise for Ellison
REM today which I've been like I haven't
slept I haven't sled we have a special
surprise for Edison Ram today so I'm
gonna go get it out of my bag you man
needs to close your eyes okay you do
close your eyes and I'm not allowed to
peek no peakies no beakies guys and I'll
tell you when you're allowed to open
your eyes okay right all right we're
back in the room do not open your eyes
right guys so keep your eyes closed
as a thank you guys for getting us to
where we need to be for giving up your
time your schedules every believing in
US facts because these men have this is
one thing that people don't really deep
here
these men have bills to pay yeah miles
to feed yeah they need to come home
every month with food on the table and
make sure that their rent is paid the
mortgage is paid
and
they dropped the security that they had
to come and be part of this yeah of two
guys just chatting [__] for a living
and that's a massive risk to take
and it has not gone unnoticed and
unappreciated so if you had an eye one
uh
say thank you for that and thank you for
getting us to where we are folks with
this little gift
hope you like it you can open your eyes
what the [__]
yo oh [__]
I don't even want to touch it
man open it yo
nah no way holy [__] [__]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so that's our gesture to you guys to say
thank you for all the hard work yeah man
yeah we appreciate you thank you so much
[__] hell
oh wow wow yeah let's go come on
come on uh yesterday you got them
yesterday yeah yeah I picked them up
yesterday anyway okay no thank you
fellas you're very welcome [__] thank
you honestly thank you
what
Jesus let's go let's go
thank you man
um it's been uh it's been a mad roller
coaster because for me I feel like I
feel like it's one of those ones where
I've always felt privileged to
first of all I was very even though I
said no from the jump I was very
privileged that you asked me to to be on
the Pod and everything I wanted to start
a pod with me or vice versa whatever and
I was like I wonder how it's gonna be
like because even though yes we laugh we
chat [__] we do all of this off camera I
wonder how that's gonna be perceived on
camera yeah because not everyone
understands our personal well they do
now but at the time not everyone
understood our Personality yeah yeah how
we liked it but you know so our circle
is pretty small yeah yeah yeah so I was
very like hmm is this gonna is this just
gonna be a hobby is this just gonna be
for fun but I obviously I'm here now
because clearly I rode the wave you know
it's it doesn't
it wasn't taking anything away from me
considering I was just spending time
with my boy and just chatting [__] it
wasn't any extra added work per se so
I'm just very very [__] grateful man
because at the end of the day I remember
times in Hospitality everyone knows I
[__] about hospitality
um or I have for the longest whilst I
was in it and I was like I remember
Christmas periods I remember us um times
in Grill on the market in London I
remember times in australasia Manchester
and I'm like
how are these men living this life on a
week to weekends to weak basis yeah and
remember every single time every single
time like we chat or in the group troll
every time you man would be doing stuff
I'd be like I can't go because I'm
working every weekend my fomo was
unbearable and not even just this
friendship group on everything else this
affected my work in Hospitality affected
my life in so many positive ways but in
so many negative ways as well and it's
like I can't believe for one I managed
to escape that and better myself as
opposed to escape and just probably
moving linear and still work in another
restaurant or whatever you know what I
mean and it's like I like I said to you
yesterday I'm not even
um
what's the one I'm looking for I'm not
really deep to really like acknowledged
the fact we've hit one million dude I
mean like it's not really sunk in yet
but as we're talking now and as these
gifts have been brought as we're in this
space I'm thinking
oh my [__] god like oh my [__] god
the amount of effort and what we've all
put in like outside of this pod we've
all worked other jobs as well as doing
this part do you know what I mean we've
all had different things to do but we
made this a priority and I'm so [__]
happy that we all had that same goal all
that had that same mindset all had that
same drive to be like this can work
because we all saw the trajectory we all
saw like the feedback we also how
how fun
it was to see other people's reactions
to us you know what I mean and it was so
good to see that oh we're getting we're
getting such a such a bigger fan base
and it's like oh we're getting DMS now
we're getting this day it started
probably started from us on absolutely
what's it called Reddit trying to find
some information sir just searching for
something to say bro yeah yeah if it
wasn't our past stories it was just
searching for stuff to say and I'm
thinking how is this going to be
sustainable that's all I kept thinking
asked me three years ago how is this
going to be sustainable yeah yeah look
at us now like we've got DMS that I
can't even open anymore because there's
they're so full and it's like
wow I never ever thought
I never if you would ask me two and a
half years ago working in Hospitality if
you had where do you think you're going
to be in two and a half years I'd
probably say I'm probably still going to
be Manchester trying to grind probably
be a GM or something like that yeah
because I was contemplating being a GM I
saw I said this to you oh I remember I
can't I was contemplating being a gem
before I was considering obviously quit
management and working on this full-time
and I'm like I wonder how different my
life would have been if this was never a
thing do you know what I mean and
words honestly cannot describe how
grateful I am honestly like I'm feeling
so emotional right now it's unfucking
believable my guys
unbelievable I love you man to death
and you guys will never understand what
you've done for me so I love you all and
thank you guys for watching obviously
it's not the end of the episode but I I
love all of you guys I'm so emotional
right now yeah I can tell it's it's
overwhelming my guy yeah overwhelming
and I can't I just can't express it so
much but yeah I love you guys to death
one million is is is a major Stone yeah
major Milestone and yeah man this is
It's upwards from here we can't we can't
go back gang right that's the selfie
stuff ever let's do it I can't ask for
these evil James glasses let's do the
energy question bro let's let's get into
it let's um if you're still with us
welcome if you're still with us thank
you
um let's get straight into the Nitty
Gritty IG question of the week was what
time what time one time where Karma was
a [__] to you
obviously the responsible juicy as well
yeah okay I made fun of my friend for
falling off his bike later that day I
got hit by a car whilst riding my bike
raw yeah I thought man's gonna say I
fell over too nah hit by a car whilst
riding my bike raw okay
okay I was a [__] girlfriend to my ex
and now the guy I'm with treats me like
a side chick
s
that's really upset that is upstairs
that's unbearable Karma I threw bread at
a duck and then got chased around the
lake by about five to eight geese
you know that's my life
you know for a fact that's my worst fear
I know I know I know he's terrified of
you have you ever been chased by a goose
bro they hiss at you no I didn't do this
thing yeah that's the intimidation yeah
yeah yeah
I've not been chased by geese bro it's
terrified I never want to be chased yeah
don't one time where Karma was a [__]
to you
I flew into state to cheat on my
girlfriend but got mugged whilst walking
to meet her at a bar
can't even explain that to the Missus
you can't you have the lies you have to
think of yeah yeah to get yourself out
of that situation
I got on a plane to cheat on my misses
that he's dummy the sense of doing that
anyway what who what this is the thing
with cheating yeah like cheating
sometimes you really really really
really really really really like you
just don't want to be a relationship
you just don't take a look in the mirror
just think what I might do actually do
it you really don't want to be getting
on a plane yeah come on bro but Tom come
on bro stop it really give up really
stop
um next I said masha'allah as I sparked
by spliff and it all fell out
oh
that's jokes I read that and died oh bro
and it all just fell out that's too
funny wow God will take everything from
you
blasphemy factual take away people have
that oh my days all fell out
there
because he knew yeah
I hooked up with an enemies girl at a
party as soon as I stepped outside I
fell and slashed both my hands
what I fell and just slashed both my
hands and enemies go yeah long wow
I got too cocky and tried a trick in
front of my friends with skates on I now
have a brain injury
foreign
injury that's permanent yeah
I don't know the severity yeah all
enemies is slurries all I know is he's
slower than someone else typed out
that's jokes
cheating on my girlfriend she got a
promotion I got fired
Peak you gotta really deep your behavior
to acknowledge her promotion as
something as calm yeah yeah you gotta
really yeah yeah sorry facts
try to give a homeless man some money he
told me it wasn't enough he chased me
and hit me
a homeless man
bro this is why I don't give homeless
people stuff that's
that's terrifying I don't I generally
don't know how I would react if I
obviously they're always sitting down
there's like a low cup or a hat however
I generally don't know how I reacts if
I'm being generous I don't give a five
or a toner
and he looks at me and says enough and
he gets to stand up oh man because I
know he's not saying it once and then
just standing up facts he'll say bro
that's not enough
that's not enough and he's standing yeah
what the [__] is going on that's not
enough I'll start looking for cameras
because it must be just like pumping you
up no no no no no no no you're terrified
that's scary because I'm just thinking
AIDS that's all I'm thinking who's a
skin touching my skin they've got
science yeah it's a placebo effect do
you think you've got it oh you think
you're going oh it's a placebo that you
touch you touch a hobo and that's it
you got scurvy
right I broke up with a man because he
only liked missionary he's now a
millionaire I should have stayed
bro that'll do anything for money in
there
he's not a millionaire I should have
stayed
that's hilarious
stuff they'll go through stuff for money
oh bro when they jump missionary forever
because he's a millionaire forever
that's boring yeah it's boring that's
boring I should have said
that's jokes oh
it doesn't oh I made fun of my friend
for having really thin eyebrows I later
lost mine in the kitchen fire
uh stuff that's horrible that is
horrible rounders I threw the ball with
all my mites to get this girl out I
dislocated my shoulder
yeah because round is one of them isn't
it
round as is that yeah it's just a little
he must have yeah launched it bottom
other side
we're in a free period and the teacher
moved my crush to stand in front of the
class and said the next person who talks
would join her I thinking this is my
moment tried to get his attention but
ended up making such a wreck as he
kicked me out the class that's happened
to me before has it geography a man
remembers yes geography I remember one
time
people were just gunning for this
flipping geography to each other
and then uh someone said something and
then one of the other kids was like
so you're not gonna do nothing okay he
said he's a kid a kid said sign to the
teacher cussing them out in some way he
said something about his haircut or his
trousers or sign okay I can't remember
what I said but basically the kid said
something to the teacher teach and then
everyone was like yeah
and then um he didn't do nothing so one
of the other kids was like sir you're
not gonna like kick him out or detention
or something exclude them or Saturn yeah
and he was like there's nothing in the
rule books that says you can't make fun
of a teacher and I said say less and I
can't remember what I said yeah but I
must have just ran my mouth yeah he said
get the [__] out when I say word for it
he said get the [__] out
the whole class oh my God
the car the cost the cost would have
gasped bro a teacher swearing a kid yeah
he said get a [__] out how was I beat
I couldn't get my words out
and when I tried to explain myself you
should do that he said get a [__] out
I'm sorry I'm in trouble ten seconds
later I was looking through the square
window like this
I was looking for scrivener like this
yeah petrified yeah I was like wrong I
thought I was gonna find out bro yeah
that's what I'm thinking bro he's gonna
ring my mom that's all I would think oh
my God ah I remember one time
I remember one time I tried to get out
of getting in trouble because um this
was back in I want to say Primary School
um I every time you get you were bad you
would receive
um or like an accumulation of being bad
accumulation of times have been bad you
receive like a letter to send to your
home
um but obviously I would get the letter
to give to my parents to read the fact
that I've been bad and they have to sign
it to acknowledge that they've read it
yeah bring it back to the school yeah
yeah everyone knows your your child is a
[__] yeah yeah but what I did was I
remember I got the thing I was thinking
I know my dad's gonna beat my ass so how
can I
get away from this yeah long story short
so obviously it's the text of what the
uh the papers for the sign and the date
and that was it so what I did was I cut
off the text and I [__] that off and I
said to my Pops that you need to sign
this for me not to go on a school trip
next week that I'm gonna stay in school
instead he signed it gave it back in I
remember specifically I can't believe I
got away with that wrong because I was
petrified I bet James I was pets because
I was like I'm not getting this ass
whooping but if I do this and I don't
succeed yeah double the ass
I believe that was petrified yeah so
yeah anyway all right he [__] signed
it yeah he signed it yeah I used to just
take that stuff to the school Forger
bro the school Florida bro everyone
school has a forger professional forger
what's your mom's name bro and they're
just
[Laughter]
yeah and I was like raw that's hilarious
School forger that's hilarious fair
enough I don't know if you had one of
them I might not have been that Circle
today yeah all I was running through but
was fair yeah and I needed an easy out
that's that's such a smart move I would
have thrown it a bin oh no but I'm
getting clocked yeah something else
back then
couldn't have it bro run away I tried I
came on B again
[__]
I tried to run away I didn't get far I
came home to beats bro
[Laughter]
I didn't get far
[__] bro it was long
long anyway two more one time where
Karma was a [__] to you
my door dashed through my food at the
door and walked off immediately and
accidentally my neighbor ran him over
before he got back into his car
imagine oh imagine bro Jesus I planned
out everything to the most perfect
detail just so I could get revenge then
on my way to start the step one I
tripped and broke my collarbone wow
that's a trip that's a buckle bro I
remember seeing one of my boys break his
collarbone in football one time I was
like yeah yeah I was screaming more than
him how did he land he landed literally
on his shoulder like someone's um side
tackled him and he was like and he just
landed like
and I was like
I mean it came up like I heard a crack I
heard a crack he said that yeah but he
was in shock
and then um he came back like like this
and I was like you good bro
I said bro you good and he was I don't
know I don't know I don't know it's
shaking as I don't know I've I've done
something yeah and I was like it's calm
his car was like just relax your
shoulder it's calm and he went at that
he screamed and cried he went like this
screamed and cried [__] and I was like
science broken back then I didn't even
know what caliber was yeah facts and he
went hospital that night yeah came back
the next day so my color was broken to
ham you've broken your toe right yeah I
broke up my skateboard you ever broken a
bow I broke my collarbone exactly that
like that Holy where I went that's uh
Secondary School
um yeah someone football winning
football winning for a tackle went over
kind of like to do like a front flip
onto your shoulder your head and your
shoulder dropped down and your bone was
just like didn't come out the skin
didn't come out of skin yeah yeah yeah
you could just see like
recovery process
not that long to be fair couple months
yeah yeah I think that oh that sounds so
scary exactly how old are you if you
remember what year were you in yeah I
want to say nine tab time I never knew
that about you same that was rattles
that's the second time I broke the same
collarbone actually oh God it was the
first time first time was in Primary
School
um I was ramping you know yeah yeah five
year six or something and me and this
kid thought it was funny to just you
know you just swinging each other around
or whatever yeah yeah he let go yeah you
flew yeah
offer that's how creative Mark got me
[__]
that's how great if Mark got me
I had a bump on me [__] that Ellis you
broken anything no I haven't actually uh
you're the lucky one yeah I know I'm
well lucky
not yet yeah touchwood Brothers [__]
guys let's take a super duper Rupa quick
break from this juicy wussy 1 million
episode two
talk to you guys and spread the word
about manscaped right guys ladies and
gentlemen it's time to unleash the beach
beasts within you this summer Landscapes
is here to help you level up your beach
game with their new beard hedger Pro kit
let's go I have it we have it we've
received it it's this is comprehensive
yeah yeah it's called I'm not gonna lie
because it was nice yeah the packaging
was nice and they gave us all the toys
yeah they gave us everything right
they're going past Waist Deep grooming
um past the waist deep grooming game and
diving in head first to your facial hair
fantasies the alliteration is mad
the beard hedger is a game changer
allowing you to shape your beard Like A
true beach babe so this summer let the
beach balls bounce hey yeah and turn
heads all over the place head on over to
manscape.com and use code sng Sierra
November golf at 20 off and free
shipping let's get back to the episode
let's go right guys
um we're back with another segment of
top five top five top five
um what are the current score seasonally
someone's got seven is it seven seven
six two yes seven six two
um yeah I feel like we've got that top
five in a minute we do top five last
week
um yeah so yeah you guys you guys ready
for top five this week yes
I'm actually going to give you guys the
option of what top five you prefer okay
to do okay there's three of us to vote
so okay cool yeah yeah yeah so we're
gonna land yeah someone's gonna land
yeah
um you can either do
one to do with
social media
or want to do with franchises I'm gonna
vote for and whichever one we don't do
we'll do next week franchises or social
media I'll say social media social media
I'm gonna say franchises franchises on
Euro social media social media cool now
um as the social media manager I'm gonna
just gonna [__] this up yeah you've
dropped yourself right top five easy the
top five most followed Instagram
accounts
wow okay [__]
okay shits and Geeks um
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I need to speak to the to the delegator
what I know you're gonna know who I'm
talking about okay
let me can I just I'll WhatsApp you from
here
you'll know who I mean when I say that
when I say what I'm saying
um I won't be going on from Google
search or anything like that okay any
other ideas but I'll message you on on
WhatsApp right now okay if that's cool
okay because you've forgotten a name
because I forgot a name I know yeah I've
forgotten her name okay I know you're
just you'll know who I'm talking about
okay right I'll wait for the message
right cool I'm going to watch that right
now you've gotten the first name
so I've given you the second name yeah
right there uh wait but I'm I've
forgotten the first name I'm going to
tell you the first I'm going to tell you
the rest yeah
from process of elimination from that I
know who you're talking about there's I
know exactly there's literally one
person right cool yeah
you know who I'm talking about but you
just can't remember the name
right
I can't even all right cool we're all
locked clearly yeah cool Ellis
give us your survive so Kim Kardashian
Drake
champagne puppy nice I didn't even think
of Drake yeah
um I've gone for NASA
I feel like that's quite a big followed
one okay fair enough you think outside
yeah sometimes bro yeah what do you
think outside the box I appreciate it uh
Kendall Jenner and then I fumbled on
this one I just bought Apple I had
[__] no idea damn you hate Instagram
in it
uh Jimmy
right so I've done Ronaldo Messi this
one
I know at one point she had the highest
Twitter so I've just I've just charged
it and put Ariana Grande uh Kim
Kardashian and Kylie Jenner
couldn't think of her names
Kim Kardashian Beyonce
ah Beyonce yeah that's a show Mr Beast
Taylor Swift hey swizzy solid shout and
Kylie Jenner so number 10 with 311
million subs or followers Khloe
Kardashian okay number nine 315 million
Beyonce
uh number seven
with 377 million Ariana Grande
number six with 388 million Dwayne The
Rock Johnson I was gonna put the rock I
put Ariana over the rock as well number
five with 398 million Kylie Jenner cool
obviously you wrote when you messaged it
to me I knew you were thinking of
specifically but when you were a
Kardashians thinking he's never going to
get it because he wrote Kardashian is
that a general
but I knew who you're trying to do you
know what I mean when you wrote all of
them down I knew you were gonna say uh
yeah
um number four with 426 million Selena
Gomez
Jesus I knew she was up there [__] yeah
didn't think about it number three with
479 million
messy guy of course
um and number two
with 597 million
so far
Cristiano Ronaldo
without code is is what you need
conviction yeah it gives me conviction
bro
and last but not least with
649 million followers the highest
followed Instagram account is
Instagram
ah touche two shades Kim K's not even
top ten
Kim K surprises me oh did I not say Kim
K no no she's number eight sorry oh
right yeah I was gonna say you you went
from you went ten nine and then you went
to did I say seven you didn't I don't
think you said eight seven or six oh I
didn't say the numbers but I just said
the names I don't know I don't know
sorry my bad Kim K is eight if I missed
out I'm sorry 363 million
um let me see if
Kim K M is the Beast is is he on this
list it was a long shot but Mr B stand
on this list Tay swizzy is number 15
268. apple is not on the list and that's
there is on the list though well played
38 but still fair play 94 million I knew
there well [__] played
is Apple on the list what's Drake Drake
is number 31 140 million well so far but
yeah well played uh so that is eight
points six points two points ggs and
that will stop dang I'm happy about that
that was top five top five top five top
five top five top five right I have a
dilemma for us today oh let's go this is
like a mild one
but it's a good topic for discussion
okay mod one isn't it it brings us back
on this Millie special it brings us back
to Our Roots about the kind of dilemmas
that we used to chat about okay before
it all got a bit too like out of control
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay right cool so
the title of this is sneaky link keeps
saying he loves me during sex
right hi guys
I've been seeing this guy casually for
about three months we don't really talk
other than when I uh go out and see him
to do up sexy time
he is a very attractive and well-known
rugby player in my city for context uh
I'm pretty sure this girl's from South
Africa so Rugby's a thing over there
yeah
just for context okay he's a very
attractive one-on rugby player in my C
and I've always assumed that he's seeing
other girls for this reason recently he
invited me to hang out with his mates
and their girlfriends and I went and had
heaps of fun but was also very confused
because I thought we were just like
casual and on the download
um
I thought we were just a casual and on
the down low kind of uh thing and I kind
of preferred it that way because my city
is small and I'm seeing someone else as
well okay on this night in Brackets he
was drunk he said he loved me while we
were having sex yeah and I ignored it
because I thought it was just in the
throes of passion
yeah
I thought he said it just in the throes
of the passion
I love you grab a face
look at your mouth I love you that yeah
over your mouth man yeah
oh
oh say [__] yeah right I thought
just in the throes of passion but it
happened again and he said it twice and
again I ignored it because we definitely
don't know each other well enough to be
saying all that damn the thought of it
uh the thought of talking to him about
it yeah makes me physically ill
from a guy's perspective is he just
saying [__] to make me obsessed with him
this is a that last question really
really intrigued me because it made me
realize that like girls
really do just think different [__] yeah
is he saying this to make me obsessed
with him no he's just saying it because
he's at the moment yeah he might not
necessarily
I I obviously feel like he's saying this
out of uh the lust of the moment I don't
genuinely think he's in love with you I
just think at that at that height at
that Peak there's nothing else to say
but [__] I love you when I'm in this Tom
you know what I mean so I think I don't
think he's saying it to confuse you what
did she say to her to what to make her
fall in love to make
um
to make me obsessed with him yeah no no
no no
unless they're like Class A manipulators
yeah they don't think about like I'm
doing this so she'll get obsessed with
yeah like why would I want you obsessed
with me relax I don't think guys want
that yeah yeah I'm already clapping the
cheeks on a regular basis why do I need
to take it the next step yeah so I don't
think um personally anyway I generally
don't think he's saying that to make you
obsessed with him yeah he's just saying
it because it's in the heat I read in
the time and the thing is with like
like for context this girl's kind of bad
okay
um so that just adds to the the mix okay
she's slightly bad
um he's getting put them on a casual
yeah but you're already seeing someone
else as well which means you're not
giving him the time of day you've
already said you don't really speak to
him unless you're banging yeah and um
yeah that's it you don't really speak to
him unless you're having sex
you said he's a well-known rugby player
so he probably already gets a lot of go
attention and you just use him for pipe
so why is she asking so I felt it's one
of them was I feel like she hmm what I'm
saying is I can see why he's saying it
because I assume he thinks he likes her
way more than he actually does
because this is a banging girl who just
sees him to bang and then doesn't chat
to him
and then she'll message him again when
she's ready to bang again and it doesn't
chat to him again my question to her is
why is she questioning whether the fact
he's saying this to make her obsessed
with him when she only hollers him for
sex she's seen someone else like he's
she said he obviously has other girls so
why would she think so I'm assuming
again could be a hot take I'm assuming
she's asking that question because she's
thinking
he wants to he's saying this so I'm
locked down for him okay solely for him
so he can carry on doing what he's doing
yeah but he knows that I'm not doing
anything else because
he's trying to pattern up exclusivity
yeah but considering she's
by the context of this conversation or
how she dm'd it seems as if she has
somewhat of control of how they bang on
when and where they bang considering she
hollers him yeah but I'm just saying she
holds him I don't know Oh I thought that
was okay okay okay I'll take that back I
thought it was verbatim okay my bad I
don't know then but I generally don't
think he's he I generally don't think
he's saying this so you can fall for him
or maybe yeah yeah I think he's guys
don't do that he's gassing yeah what
guys do do is the gases yeah they gas
themselves up in the moment when they
say stuff and they also don't like when
girls treat them like they're meat they
we like it for a small amount of time
because it is sexy yeah because it's
banging but then after a few months yeah
it's like you actually don't care about
me
you actually don't care about me and
it's mad yeah so then they they like
they think they like you we think well
we think we like you more than we
actually do because we we actually don't
know that we've got you
um I'm not I'm not ready to drop L bars
but this whole like bringing you out
with his brethrens and their misses and
all them things like that I've never
done that but I can see like a case of
like
dude does this girl even like me or not
yeah yeah I hear that okay um sometimes
guys can do the most but they love you
ting I've been in some cheeks and I've
said some stuff I don't think I've ever
I've never run that bar I don't think
unless it's like with a girl I'm seeing
like my girlfriend at the time but I
don't think there's any like link or
whatever I've been banging and said I
love you I've never said I love you the
first time in cheeks oh definitely I've
said it when I'm drunk definitely not
I've said it when I'm drunk what like
not in cheeks just like on a dance floor
no no not in person over text on the
dust I've just had I don't know who
knows why I just had to go
yeah imagine
on like a way back from the club oh
McDonald's she's all I can think about
okay all I could think about it I didn't
see you go tonight yeah yeah I didn't
see anyone but gargoyles yeah yeah on
that dance floor tonight I want you yeah
I love you okay I [__] love you okay
okay
yeah why did I say that bro because all
she replied was pre-ice
why did I say that bro what did I give
her my heart like that yeah because I'm
in a pocket yeah thanks just these drunk
inhibitions yeah
drunk inhibitions but yeah so that one's
a mad one but yeah you need to nip it in
the butt you do you do
um
considering I feel like it's just one of
them ones where you I feel like you want
to you want to believe more than what he
says with the I love you things it's
just just take it as he's saying stuff
whilst you're [__] yeah I would I
would go as far to say as he thinks he
wants more with you than he actually
does yeah so keep it keep it as it is if
you're happy as it is keep it as it is
because he's going to want to push and
push and push it more yeah until he
knows for a fact that like you're down
for him yeah and once he knows that for
a solidified fact he'll bring it as
casual he'll just stop replying yeah so
once you're locked in he'll stop
replying yeah just keep it as trying to
hold as much control as you can for your
own sanity and dignity I guess or facts
yes exactly true fam true bro that's
that's the bar that even is true
um right okay cool you've got the number
to finish us off as well help me Smash
gang so I'm 23 female oh gang I was 99
this is a prayer and I've been good good
friends with this man 34 for about three
years we text all day speak on the phone
I speak on the phone a lot have TV shows
you watch together very close
relationship he has a girl
been with her 10 years and often tells
me that he knows she's not his soul mate
she's boring and not physically his type
anymore
but they've got a mortgage a dog and he
can't be asked with a hassle of ending
it all
he told me she doesn't know about me
because if she saw what I looked like
she'd be suspicious so he just hides his
phone and she works nights so calls he
calls me sees me then anyway I need to
[__] I've fully been trying I've fully
been trying for like six months now and
I don't know where I'm going wrong
I [__] all the married men with kids
easier than this
he's not hugely Flay but we talk slash
joke about sex easy Etc and he'll ask
he'll ask me for advice for he'll ask me
for advice on other girls he finds
attractive
question about question mark So He
Cheats
or he's or he's willing to at least he
compliments me and is real and it's real
with me about my appearance Etc I even
um if I ever have to ask him
he gets gassed when I wear my glasses
starts calling me trouble and it and it
kills me
however
however he has never had a single drink
around me and Point Blank refuses to as
he says bad things will happen and he
can't risk it even once said they were
great in nine months with the pre-ice
how do I move to this man I've I've been
sold this whole time but do I just send
him nudes or some [__]
I've been sold by all I said is nudes
how do I move to I thought that's what
he said all right but what do I send him
nudes
um for context we work together and are
both managers of different departments
so I always have tension Sly lives in
meetings like we have some dirty secret
and it [__] turns me on
we're both leaving at the end of July
and he wants to do some big night out
together and with everyone get hotels
for
ETC is this my chance please you don't
need to finish 100 that's the chance
that's the moment that's the moment
please help I can't explain how much I
want him to destroy me literally on my
phone to him writing this laugh out loud
the need is too strong thank you
really yeah
and she tidy I haven't seen the pictures
that made me itch bro oh do you need a
do you need a recap oh yeah
[Laughter]
yeah Daddy sees it all in 4k
um bro the tension with my hair stand on
edge sexual touch is the one yeah so
right
um he wants to bang you oh of course
he's given such obvious Vibes that he
wants of course he does it's not even
funny a man's complimenting on her looks
said you'll regret it in nine months
yeah don't wear those glasses your
trouble yeah like he wants the bank
talking about okay cool one thing one
thing you can say for a fact yeah is
that if a guy which is also in my books
like this is unforgivable Behavior yeah
slagging off the love of your life oh
that doesn't run bro talking [__] on
your wife to the girl you're too cool
this [__] no yeah yeah never runs yeah
she is a [__] yeah and this is your
life yeah yeah yeah stop yeah talk it if
a guy's ever willing to talk [__] on his
wife to you one he won million percent
wants to bang that is a red flag and two
it's a screeching red flag red flag he's
a weak man he's a weak weak man
um so that red flag [__] this guy from
that jump yeah anyway yeah he wants to
bang you he's down to bang you yeah
um
if you don't want to wait until this
whole flip in night outing head into the
toilets bend over the sink and take a
pic write that skirt up and take a pic
send it to him send it to him see how
quick he gets it so you've got 30
seconds to get here he'll be there in
four seconds
I couldn't receive that do you think I
could
I could have received do you think I
could in the office with the red lace
glasses on them trouble glasses on the
Red Lace bent over the sink
I could have received that
yeah workplace sexual tension scary is
is a scary scary thing I feel like
everyone's been there but it's it's so
it's literally the only terrible thing
about working in office facts it's the
only thing you can stand about like in
office
and if she's not in oh poor man
why am I here yeah bro I'm done I don't
need to make money today yeah yeah 100
charge this day yeah facts let me go
home to the love of my life
stupid why am I here bro I'm bored oh
worse days when she's not in yeah um but
yeah I never said he wants to smash he
wants to smash he's gonna smash you so
you can either do it now or you can wait
I don't know what you're concerned about
I will give him a like one percent of
props to the fact that he refuses to
drink around you that's interesting yeah
because he knows because he actually
knows he will take you down yeah so it
doesn't sound like he's too proud about
it yeah um but one minute as soon as he
starts lagging off the love of his life
that I promise you it's Paul from him
and he's down to two yeah 100 yeah [__]
that guy
um but anyway guys slightly different
episode today I know it's not exactly
what you guys are used to I appreciate
if you made it this far we really really
appreciate you again thank you so much
for a million
um
after this point I honestly like I want
obviously we're gonna want two million
five million 10 million but at the end
of the day I will never ever ever ask
anything else obviously we're going to
do the usual subscribe to the channel
but like in terms of goals and all this
kind of stuff like guys you've done it
for us we've completed our mission and
we couldn't we couldn't be happier man
could not be happier it's crazy um so
again thank you thank you thank you
um if you want to see us on Thursday
head on over to patreon.com and as
always
[Music]
foreign